you just pointed at the screen Wesley
and you were surprised by that the
lifetime matchup score as well yeah why
why is it so uh
well because a very strong player and I
think the wins I had him against
I had against him in the classical was
like seven years ago so it was such a
long time ago I think
but I don't even remember beating him
four times I think I remember the thing
filled cup and then London chess classic
and then uh
where else did I beat him I don't even
think felt Cup London chess classic
2016-17 I don't even remember the
probably a long time ago it must have
been a long time we don't know for sure
I don't even remember but one thing
Wesley I wanted to ask you sum up the
last couple of days for you because
Croatia yes
such difficult days right such difficult
matchups both the one with Hikaru but
today's matchup was very very difficult
as well and nothing it separates you
with the white pieces you were getting
something in both matches but totally
winning yeah totally winning exactly but
then towards the end when you had only
seconds on the clock it felt like nerves
were taking over did you feel that way
as well yeah basically animal was
winning but
I mean I don't really mind that much
what happens I mean I didn't find the
Lebanese a great and wonderful player
also so it's Fabi but uh I mean I don't
find the matches real difficult I'm just
very happy to still be in the tournament
that all that matters I still got one
life left and uh get my main focus
this year and last year was classical
chef although it doesn't seem I'm
getting nowhere with it but uh what
happens in Blitz and rap it doesn't
really matter that much to me I'm just
full of classical if I win good if not
that's fine too but today was obviously
a wonderful day and I'd like to glorify
the Lord Jesus and that's a very
interesting thing you say about mental
fortitude and in those difficult moments
you know you're winning with the white
pieces you lose that one right against
you come back but then you take it to
the Blitz and then unfortunately losing
that one what did you tell yourself at
night to get back into this competition
and make sure you win today's match well
it wasn't easy I think for any player
it's not easy to
lose a winning game but I just my mom
helped me but my I just tell myself that
this is part of the game that's what
chess is about uh
Sometimes the best player wins sometimes
it doesn't happen and you know mistakes
are
part of the game then my secret is just
to keep improving keep improving you
know there'll always be missed chances
always gonna be blunders made but
uh
he just tried to keep improving to
increase your rating
and if the chips fall hair away and it's
good if nothing just keep working keep
working keep playing these tournaments
keep trying right yeah that's why
they're not here I'm like the only
player who doesn't have a rest day in
the room and I also think this is my
fifth tournament in a row I've been
playing non-stop for eight weeks played
in why I can't say click it played in
Dusseldorf
also played some online so uh but uh
you know I love Jeff I'm very grateful
to the thing Fields the Saint Louis
chess club for hosting tournaments like
this giving people like me and linear
work and uh
you know if it if it goes your way then
that's good if if not just try to keep
getting now that's a very interesting
thing you mentioned you've been playing
for a lot of weeks and we were
discussing this in the studio as well
what do you do to keep your physical
shape ready for this type of stretch
stretches yeah the fun thing that could
be improved upon
like I was reading about Bobby Fischer
in the museum and that's one thing he's
really really good at he's so he's so
physically strong and so is Magnus
Carlsen so that's definitely one thing I
could improve upon but try to
yes I try to exercise either take long
walks during a tournament
I try to swim when I'm back home swim
two or three times a week for an hour
uh I tried to also eat healthy
when I was younger I could eat anything
I wanted
I'm getting close to 30. the doctor told
me I have to watch my diet here and
there
and uh
try to you know eat healthier try to eat
more fruits and vegetables try to sleep
12 hours every night 12 hours okay okay
yeah I mean it's not easy but I try to
learn better on 13 hours a night
because during the game
um you need your full concentration when
when I'm back at home I don't really
need much sleep but when I'm in a
tournament try to get as much as
possible also so on Bobby Fisher's
interview he he wakes up like an hour
half an hour before the game so he comes
to the game very fresh uh for me it's a
bit different like I do some review here
and there but I usually wake up around
three two and a half hours before a game
that's very interesting and very
revealing thank you for telling us all
these secrets I know Magnus that's the
thing he just wakes up and then goes
play a game and maybe that's a secret
but I tried to learn from great players
guys join the conversation well uh first
of all just simply our congratulations
you're in the finals and uh you're very
very deserving I know what you mean
about that free day Wesley it could have
gone your way uh yes uh yesterday but
you you you came back and the
elimination and so just a hat tip well
done and just yeah keep going good Joby
yeah no I just also wanted to say
congratulations and
I wanted to ask you about your
preparations for today actually because
obviously you've been playing classical
games and then you had to switch to the
rapid against Lavon how did you adjust
uh well I just you know
again just try to sleep well not try not
to stress myself too much just try to be
very relaxed very calm I took a look at
some of the one's recent openings
prepared some small ideas here and there
uh but nothing really stressful maybe
for I just prepared chess for half an
hour and then uh
I slept yes listen to music as they
usually do okay watch a movie try to get
the relax turn in good shape and I think
I played pretty pretty decently today
like I looked I look at some of my games
with no computer I think I played pretty
okay so that's uh that's a very good
sign but after this tournament I'll have
a five week break so I I look forward to
watching the world championship match
Ian and ending and spending some rest
before going to Christian's Hometown
Romania yes yes yeah yeah I'll see you
there for sure that should be an
interesting one we'll have to get our
ticket and try to arrive a few days
early
Wesley thank you very much for joining
the show congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thanks again our
congratulations Wesley